jean castex était dans le vaucluse cet
après midi auprès d'agriculteurs qui n'a
promis de ne pas laisser tomber alors
qu'on s'est quand même extravagant dans
deux jours mais il a dit que le
gouvernement ne laisserait pas tomber
secteur c'était un de ses tout derniers
déplacements en tant que croyants c'est
dire si l'urgence commande sur ce sujet
alors qu'on sait que 15 départements ont
déjà dépassé le seuil d alerte comme
nous raconte samia de sheer
des terre craquelée des nappes
phréatiques de moins en moins fourni la
sécheresse s'installe en france en avril
le déficit de pluie a atteint 30 à 70%
selon les régions un manque d'eau qui
aura des conséquences sur les cultures
dans le loiret il a plu moitié moins que
la normale depuis le début de l'année
2022 là je peux même pas prendre de
terre aujourd'hui vous voyez c'est c'est
du béton c'est sec voilà il ya plus
aucune fraîcheur pour sauver la récolte
de blé il faut tirer gay au risque de ne
plus avoir assez d'eau pour le maïs au
mois d'août l'hiver on a trop d'eau
l'été on en a plus assez sur l'année la
quantité d'eau sont toujours les mêmes
sauf qu'on est des plus grandes et plus
en plus d'amplitude c'est à dire on a
trois mois de pluie ensuite trois mois
de siècle et aujourd'hui si on stoppe
pas l'eau pendant qu'on a
les périodes très humide qu'on pouvoir
utiliser pour les périodes sèches ont
fait ressortir si la pluie ne vient pas
les cultures de printemps comme le
tournesol seront elles aussi menacées
d'après les prévisions de météo france
la vague de chaleur va se poursuivre
avec les conditions anticycloniques
qu'on attend fin qu'on a en ce moment et
qu'on attend pour les prochains jours ça
donc ça nous protège des épisodes des
perturbations qui circulent plus au nord
est donc en effet à ça ça va poser ça va
pas arranger les soldes c'est con ça va
permettre d'assécher encore plus ses
sols donc c'est quelque chose à
surveiller également pour tenter de
préserver la ressource en eau quinze
départements ont pris des mesures de
restriction qui vont de la simple
vigilance jusqu'à l'interdiction totale
de laver sa voiture ou d'arroser un
espace vert par endroits
la sécheresse on en parle ce soir avec
mes invités magali régler à bonsoir vous
êtes maître de conférences en géographie
à l'école normale supérieure co
directrice du centre de formation sur
l'environnement et la société a le nsrs
toujours et membre du haut conseil pour
le climat j'accueille aussi frédéric
denhez bonjour journaliste écrivain
chroniqueur habitué de ces deux sens
public écologue vous vous dites est
votre dernier ouvrage rencontre avec des
échos le remarquable chez delachaux et
niestlé et ça et puis enfin hermine
chombart de l'oeuvre vous êtes délégué
juste pas je le prends bien créé bras
vous êtes délégué général du conseil
national pour la résilience alimentaire
et nous nous raconter ce que c'est que
cette institution que peu de français
connaissent sans doute parmi nos
téléspectateurs et puis bien sûr
laeticia qui est resté avec moi pour
pour cette seconde partie de l'émission
mais avant de commencer je voudrais
c'est un poids sur le diagnostic déjà
avec vous ma galerie gaza est-ce que la
sécheresse est déjà là où est-ce qu'il
arrive et pourquoi alors on a
effectivement une sécheresse qui est en
train de se conjuguer à une vague de
chaleur c'est un peu différent d'accord
la sécheresse en fait c'est un déficit
de précipitations il ne pleut pas assez
et donc effectivement on manque d'eau
est actuellement on manque d'eau sur une
période cruciale qui est celle où les
végétaux sont en train de monter de
sortir et donc c'est là que les épices
forme c'est là que les grains se
remplissent et donc même s'il ne pleut
il pleut dans quelques semaines sa
présence et c'est comme pour un bébé qui
grandit si vous voulez il ya des moments
de la croissance ou si c'est pas mis en
place ça se rattrape pas et donc on a
ces agriculteurs aujourd'hui
effectivement qui sont dans une période
critique pour les récoltes ce qu'on
appelle la montée en rendement est donc
là ils vont avoir des pertes de
rendement par ailleurs lorsqu'il ne
pleut pas maintenant parce qu'il n'a pas
plus dans les mois précédents on peut le
voir sur cette infographie vrai que
depuis le début de l'année on a un
déficit de
35 pensent alors csii peu comme entre 40
% et 30 % selon les mois depuis le début
de l'année et en plus ce qui se passe
c'est que nos végétaux pour l'instant
ils ont encore des racines assez assez
fait part assez peu de sites qui n'ont
pas assez profondément dans les sols
donc même si on a une immunité profonde
des sols la couche superficielle elle
n'est pas à s'arroser et donc ça ça
s'ajoute en plus à une vague de chaleur
qui arrive on a eu par ailleurs et ça
malheureusement ce sont des tendances
lourdes qui sont en train de se mettre
en place sur le territoire en gros ce
qu'on nous dit c'est qu'avec un crime
acquis changer le climat il a déjà
changé depuis 1901 on est en france à
peu près 1 degré cet et bien on va avoir
des étés plus long des hivers plus doux
et des printemps plus précoce et donc
commençons à une variabilité plus grand
des précipitations on a une variabilité
aussi plus grand des moments d'épisodes
extrêmes et ce qui est en train de se
passer les téléspectateurs l'ont
peut-être vu c'est que il ya eu en début
d'année un des bourgeons précoce qui
sont arrivés avec du gel précoce c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui en fait on voit que
beaucoup de secteurs de l'agriculture
sont touchés et ça change les effets
boule de neige parce que ces végétaux
savent aussi alimenter le bétail et
d'envoyer que derrière en fait cette
sécheresse qui qui pas si exceptionnel
que ça pour l'instant c'est vrai que
c'est très tôt dans l'année mais ces
déficits ils sont pas non plus extrêmes
amène des conseils ce prix il ya des
déficits sur les nappes phréatiques
aussi alors qu'ils n'ont pas tous
remplis on va le voir sur cette sur
cette infographie qui s'affiche à
l'écran normalement voilà l aie on est
les vrilles est normal ou os et en gris
monnaies remet en bas ça commence à
rosir est très bas c'est dans les
couleurs bordeaux marouane vous voyez
d'ailleurs que la carte n'est pas
exactement superposée à celle des
départements en vigilance parce qu'en
fait dans les sécheresses il ya
plusieurs types de sécheresse est les
sécheresses qui sont les sécheresses -o
déficit de précipitations il peut pas
assez donc scellé sécheresse du sol
ensuite on va voir des sécheresses aux
niveaux des cours d'eau qui sont aussi
liées à des déficits de nappes et puis
progressivement on va avoir des
sécheresses aussi qu'ils voyaient
simplement à la végétation parce qu'il
fait chaud ça transpire et donc est donc
en fait on a eu un cumul de sécheresse
différentes qui peuvent se conjuguer qui
vont au moment dé et effectivement donné
des problèmes c'est pour ça que les
cartels sont pas exactement
superposables et que ce sont pas les
mêmes effets en fonction là aussi de la
nature des sols si vous êtes sur des
sols calcaires sur des sceaux l'énergie
le ya beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui qui
dans quelques mois risquent d'avoir un
nouveau défi sur sur leur maison c'est
ce qu'on appelle les seiches réseau
technique voilà donc si vous venez à
tout va venir à toutes ses conséquences
d'expliquer parce que finalement c'est
plein de mécanismes physiques qui avait
d'une part par leur ampleur mais aussi
par le moment où il se passe d'accord
juste une question frédéric dans
l'espace et dans les yeux votre nom
c'est mieux c'est plus joli est normal
quand on dit l'été sera chaud qu'est ce
que ça vous les prévisions
météorologiques à deux ou trois mois
rien bien au delà de huit jours déjà les
ingérences météo france ont du mal à
établir des prévisions parce qu'un bruit
de fond énorme parce que c'est des
ordinateurs qui embrassent des des
milliards et des milliards de données et
donc forcément statistiquement la
probabilité que vous vous trompiez
augmente avec le temps dans cuit jours
c'est déjà beaucoup qu'un jeu alors vous
imaginez les gens j'en ai eu un hier sur
un plateau d'une autre chaîne qui me
disaient mais l'été sera caniculaire nom
pouvait pas dire ça on n'en sait rien on
n'en sait rien et on en sait d'autant
d'autant moins rien si j'ose dire c'est
de ces affreuses que je viens de dire
que l'eau est devenue encore plus
imprévisible qu'avant donc plus personne
n'est capable même au brgm cantat au
remplissage notre personne n'est capable
de prévoir l'avenir de prévoir le
remplissage des nappes personne n'est
capable de prévoir la pluviométrie avant
c'était simple la france la france béni
des dieux parce que l'eau coule tout le
temps lui est partout c'est fini on se
retrouve avec une situation qui se
rapproche un peu de celle d'autres pays
comme les pays du maghreb où comme vous
l'avez dit on a des saisons très marquée
avec une incapacité à dire à prévoir
l'eau qu'il va y avoir donc peut-être
demain de prévoir les récoltes que l'on
pourra faire et donc ça ça vient un vrai
enjeu évidemment que soient politiques
sociétales et économiques
juste je voudrais vous nous parler juste
en un mot de de votre association qu'on
ne connaît pas forcément bien le conseil
national pour la résilience alimentaire
et savoir si vos membres sont préoccupés
justement par cette question de l'eau 1
vous savez difficile le cnra donc à
vraiment pour vocation à la fois de dire
que ben c'est urgent il faut qu'on se
mobilise pour la résilience de nos
territoires pour la transition agricoles
et en même temps de dire il existe plein
de solutions parce que c'est pas le tout
de dire allez-y yakafokon mais il ya
plein de solutions plein d'innovations
qui répondent à ces enjeux de la fourche
à la fourchette comme on dit à tous les
niveaux il y à des acteurs des
innovations qui répondent aux enjeux et
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
qu'ils soient actifs qui passe à
l'échelle et qu'ils soient tout de suite
moi donc c'est un groupe d'agriculteurs
des consommateurs
toute la chaîne de valeur et le sujet de
l'eau c'est une préoccupation sur moi
bah évidemment sur le début de la chaîne
de valeur bien évidemment c'est une
préoccupation alors on n'a pas fait un
bail storming spécifique sur sur ce
sujet là mais évidemment c'est une
préoccupation tout il ya eu les grands
défis de l'agroécologie ça fait partie
de justement de ce qui peut permettre de
retenir l'eau qu'on appelle l'eau verte
si je me trompe pas donc c'est celle qui
est capté par les sols et qu'ils
profitent précisément à toutes ces
cultures qui sortent en ce moment et ça
fait partie des solutions qui sont
envisagées qui se sont diffusées et qui
doivent être définies nécessaire
frédéric l'évoquait il ya des
spécialistes ils font un parallèle pas
qu'il dise que l'été sera très chaud
pour des parallèles entre l'été convient
là et même l'été 76 cas marqué les
esprits des plus vieux d'entre nous je
me mets dedans évidemment aussi voilà
qui été l'épisode le plus important en
france à l'époque il est le gouvernement
enfin avait même décidé de créer un
impôt sécheresse oui tout à fait c'est
jacques chirac juste avant de partir
alors on sait que vous aviez six ans
donc après on calculera
jacques chirac juste avant de donner sa
démission en août
1976 des blocs 2,2 milliards de francs
pour venir en aide aux agriculteurs car
ce sont eux qui souffrent le plus de
cette sécheresse qui touchent
spécifiquement le nord ouest de la
france et c'est une sécheresse qui est
particulièrement aigu parce qu'elle a
commencé dès l'automne 75 ans qu'elle
dure cette sécheresse dans toute
l'europe de l'ouest on le voit
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on a une photo
qui est passée voilà d'une agricultrice
avec son sol craquelé ce sont les
exactement les mêmes images qu'on a
passées dans notre sujet d'ouverture
donc vous voyez c'est toujours la même
problématique
et c'est vrai que l'état décide après un
fait divers le suicide d'un agriculteur
de 28 mai dans la foulée l'opinion
publique bien sûr et ému et l'état
débloque des grands moyens comme l'armée
par exemple qui va s'occuper de récolter
de transporter le fourrage vers les
régions qui souffrent le plus et
certains pour ces choses ont été bien
accueillis par la population eh bien non
ni par les agriculteurs qui disent baïse
avant entre 200 francs et 500 francs par
tête de bétail des c'est pas assez et
alors surtout pas à parler mais gros et
moyens contribuables qui ont vu leur
impôt sur le revenu augmenter de 10 %
donc non mesures impopulaires ils sont à
son départ de matignon d'ailleurs
jacques chirac laisse quand même un
petit cadeau empoisonné à raymond barre
et qui arrive juste pour la petite
histoire de petit aspect politique pour
la petite histoire et pour ré ancré dans
aujourd'hui dans l'époque actuelle
en 1976 le gouvernement aurait très bien
pu emprunter pour financer cet impôt
sécheresse et il a décidé de ne pas
augmenter de ne pas alourdir la dette du
pays alors faire un petit point sur les
conséquences de cette situation en
essayant de comprendre qui souffre et en
commençant par ceux qui souffrent le
plus aguerri culture qui souffre le plus
oui il est alors ça d'ailleurs c'est pas
spécifique à la france a aujourd'hui les
premières victimes les lélés les
premières les premiers métiers en direct
des impacts du changement climatique ce
sont les agriculteurs
qui souffrent doublement parce que d'une
part effectivement ils sont déjà dans
une situation de crise fort endettement
on connaît en la crise du monde agricole
quand on parle du suicide des
agriculteurs on sait aujourd'hui les
difficultés du monde agricole est là
dessus donc il arrive effectivement mais
toutes ces variations du milieu
elle se rajoutent est donc là on va
avoir des risques d'endettement va avoir
des revenus qui vont s'effondrer et puis
derrière ce que cette session historique
c'est le plus gros déficit depuis 25 ans
la présente deux historiques et non
historique c'est à dire que là aussi ce
sont des extrêmes on n'est pas encore
sûr d'arriver à ce qui s'est passé en 76
mais effectivement c'est le cumul si
vous voulez ce qui est terrible c'est ce
cumul ce cumul des crises on aussi
appris le vide qui s'articule là aussi
avec la crise ukrainienne avec
l'ensemble des bassins aujourd'hui de
production du blé de l'orge notamment en
europe qui est touché donc avec des
effets dominos sur le reste des marchés
parce qu'évidemment cette agriculture
elle est extrêmement insérés dans les
marchés est devenu un questionnement sur
le rôle de l'europe pour protéger aussi
ses agriculteurs une pac qui va tomber
pas toujours dans mon sens on pourra y
revenir et donc cet agriculteur ils sont
en direct si vous voulez qu'ils se
prennent tous dans l'express nous a dit
qu'en plus que séoul est responsable
parce qu'effectivement aux gens ce
qu'ils on consomme beaucoup exactement
et aujourd'hui est ce que dit très bien
le giec et je suis content d'entendre
dire qu'il faut parler de solution c'est
que logique des mondes que l'agriculture
c'est un problème c'est en gros postes
d'émissions mais c'est aussi une des
solutions majeures sinon la première
solution au changement climatique
pourquoi parce qu'on a des ddd un budget
énorme pour gagner du co2 est complice
et agriculteurs il parlait sol par les
végétaux et par la préservation de la
biodiversité sans laquelle nos mains
même dans les sociétés les plus
développés même ici en france pour ne
peut pas vivre demain y'a plus
d'abeilles a plus de poissons ya le
regard doit être comme très compliqué
ils sont cette solution est donc on a
besoin d'avoir aujourd'hui une
transition un soutien pour effectivement
arrêter de faire de la mesure est au
delà de la rustine est vraiment faire de
ces agriculteurs une solution au
problème parce que ça touche aussi des
forêts sécheresse ça touche aussi
et ça touche tout et c'est surtout les
sols comme magali l'a dit le coeur du
problème est la clé de voûte de notre
adaptation au changement climatique
c'est les soldes je suis devenu un
obsédé des sols personne ne parle des
sols c'est même juridiquement ça
n'existe pas les seuls en france ça
n'existe que si vous en faites quelque
chose dans le code de l'environnement
est un livre sur l'eau un livre sur la n
ya pas de livres sur les sols le soulier
il y est la propriété privée donc on n'y
touche pas on ne veut pas le voir or les
sols ça l'avantagé d'un puits carbone
d'être un pull à od train une fontaine à
une fontaine de biodiversité dont demain
l'agriculture mais aussi les villes sera
obligé de beaucoup moins mal traiter les
sols la première cause de maltraitance
si j'ose dire c'est les labours profonds
et trop fréquents et de les laisser
couvert en permanence entre les cultures
ça c'est fondamental c'est la
conservation des sols est ce que font de
plus en plus de villes c'est d'ouvrir la
voirie pour laisser les sols libéré de
façon à ce qu'ils puissent absorber
l'eau de pluie laquelle eau de pluie
sera dépollué naturellement par le sol
ira rejoindre ainsi eu moins polluer les
réseaux et les nappes n'ira pas grossir
les réseaux d'eaux pluviales et puis il
rabroue v des arbres qui feront de
l'ombre en était hors jeu résume un peu
ça par edel mais c'est ce qui est en
train de se faire ch en train de faire
un sujet la jeune vie c'est ce qui est
en train de se faire et ça a démarré à
doué il ya une trentaine d'années à
l'agencé de l'eau artois picardie mais
comme un point de vue plus estivales si
j'ose dire parce que la sécheresse plus
la chaleur c'est aussi des incendies
pour les foires est enfin possible et
cela provoque un risque incendie
augmente en france on sait il est encore
moins prévisible avons par contre tout
ce que l'on sait c'est que la leyre de
répartition des incendies ne fait
qu'augmenter vers le nord vers le sud
vers l'ouest vers l'est partout même là
même les vosges les pompiers ont estimé
que les vosges et aussi compte tenu des
plantations douglas dégueulasse qui sont
en train d'arriver en fin de vie qui
sont maintenant tout sec parce qu'ils
meurent sur pied il suffit d'une petite
allumette et tout flamberait d'un coup
donc effectivement c'est la capacité
qu'auront les sols à absorber de l'eau
sera demain essentiel et donc le travail
qu'on va demander à l'agriculture c'est
attention faites faites en sorte que vos
sols est une capacité à absorber l'eau
de pluie et que vous ville vous aussi
vous développiez cette capacité en
ouvrant maximum de soldats alors des
conséquences pour les agriculteurs pour
les sols pour les particuliers un mini
show bar de los c'est vraiment
l'inflation la con
agir quand même sur cette histoire de
sol parce que on est en train de
travailler avec afnor normalisation pour
mettre en place une un référentiel un
cadre de bonne pratique en fait pour les
collectivités territoriales pour que
justement elle puisse relever tous les
défis et les enjeux sur leur territoire
j'ai organisé cet atelier là entre
décembre et février juste avant le salon
de l'agriculture il y avait un atelier
conte a intitulé bien commun donc bien
commun il ya évidemment le sol les sols
l'eau on a eu beaucoup de difficulté à
avoir les personnes autour de la table
que ce soit des collectivités où que ce
soit des des acteurs économiques est-ce
que ce sujet là il est très important
mais comme il est la base de tout ça
appartient en fait à tout le monde c'est
super ça sur le cul mais c'est
exactement dans les personnes sont
occupées ont surtout comprends pas bien
donc c'est pour ça aussi que dans ce
qu'on propose il y a une grosse part de
formation de il ya beaucoup d'acteurs
qui accompagne qui sensibilise à
l'importance des sols et pour faire le
lien aussi avec ce que disait magali les
agriculteurs quand ils sont en place ils
ont tous les monuments mais c'est aussi
les héros on a besoin d'eux avec un
adulte et et os à la fin 0 et 2 pour la
transition alimentaire et une fois
qu'ils sont en place une fois qu'ils
travaillent au quotidien mais ils n'ont
plus le temps de se former d'être
sensibilisés à tous ces enjeux là on
leur met tout de suite ils sont de très
très très sollicités donc comment est ce
que on peut entre guillemets
rétropédaler sensibiliser dès le lycée
agricole à ces enjeux là oui ça c'est ça
c'est un programme sur le sur le long
terme mais c'est très intéressant on va
venir aux solutions j'ai juste pour
terminer sur ce chapitre des
conséquences on a parlé évidemment
l'agriculture il ya aussi la question
les conséquences industrielles de je
pense notamment au secteur du nucléaire
parce que c'est jean luc mélenchon l'a
souligné avant-hier dans un tweet avec
un os qu'on peut voir sur l'écran et
c'est en disant qu'il y avait un lien on
sait qu'ils me centrale dans le
bordelais les scènes voilà qui a été
arrêté parce que le circuit de
réchauffement de on a besoin d'une eau
qui soit suffisamment fraîche pour
refroidir et puis surtout surtout au
lieu d'une certaine température les
industriels dont le nucléaire n'ont pas
le droit de rejeter dans les rivières
une eau si elles dépassent une certaine
température pour des raisons de respect
de la biodiversité
mais il ya un risque pour la production
par louis gérardin conserve la garde ils
attendent qu'elle se rafraîchissent et
ensuite il la libère il ya un risque
pour la production d'électricité oui oui
mais après
enfin ça on observe on observe depuis
tout le temps faim en 76 il y avait il
ya eu pas nucléaire mais c'étaient des
usines à charbon de production de
d'énergie à partir du charbon elle aussi
avait besoin d'être réfrigérée elles
n'ont pas été puis ça a été quand même
c'est un petit risque je pense mais qui
pourrait s'accroître demain
effectivement c'est sûr qu'avec des
éoliennes et des panneaux
photovoltaïques ça va mieux l oms a
besoin d'être refroidit mais quand on
est un anticyclone tels que le nokia
aucune éolienne qui tourne bompard alors
si ça touche tous les agriculteurs et
industriels la société les sols des
forêts il faut peut-être trouver des
solutions et donc avant de trouver des
solutions à long terme et à la réponse
politique à court terme on va en parler
parce que jean castex et est aujourd'hui
dans le vaucluse aux côtés
d'agriculteurs on va faire le point avec
marion vigreux sur les mesures déjà
annoncées aux mises en place par le
gouvernement
rebonjour dans l'es11 alors
qu'elle a été la politique de la réponse
du gouvernement à cette sécheresse qui
s'annonce vous l'avez évoqué au début de
ce débat signe que le gouvernement se
mobilise plusieurs ministres dont jean
castex était cet après midi dans le
vaucluse pour rencontrer des
agriculteurs directement exposées à ce
risque ils ont notamment visité le
bassin de l'oasis du canal de carpentras
pour évoquer la problématique de
l'irrigation que l'état a décidé de
soutenir via plusieurs mesures
financières si l' enveloppe dédiée à la
modernisation des techniques
d'irrigation des agriculteurs a été
doublé elle passe de 20 à 40 millions
d'euros et doit permettre aux
exploitants de développer des systèmes
plus économe en lots fin avril le
gouvernement a également autorisé les
agences de l'eau a dépensé 100 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour financer
des projets d'accès à l'eau comme par
exemple la construction de retenues ou
deux bassan pour stocker les excédents
en eau de pluie à ce jour une centaine
de projets sont en cours de
développement sur le territoire et puis
pour limiter la consommation d'eau douce
la réutilisation des eaux usées va
également être autorisé dans certains
cas notamment pour certains procédés
industriels enfin le pouvoir des préfets
va être renforcée afin de faciliter et
d'accélérer à les projets locaux de
gestion de l'eau à noter que le
ministère de l'agriculture veut
également pouvoir anticiper ces épisodes
de sécheresse en évaluant par exemple
les volumes d'eau qui peuvent être
prélevés et stockés en hiver durant la
période des autos car pour l'état la
gestion de cette chez serait-ce de cette
sécheresse perdure a dit m c'est dur à
dire elle est cruciale et oui pour
l'exécutif pas question de voir la
production française agricole ralenti
est pénalisé par cette sécheresse car en
toile de fond c'est notre souveraineté
alimentaire qui est en jeu puisque pour
amortir les conséquences de la guerre en
ukraine il faut aujourd'hui produire
plus mais gagnent ce sont des mesurettes
sont nécessaires ces mesures c'est de la
réponse de court terme et c'est
nécessaire ou pour vous c'est du
saupoudrage les deux mon général
pourquoi parce que effectivement
comprends très bien et quel que soit le
gouvernement en place quand il ya une
crise et la crise actuelle est très
forte sur amont agricole on l'a déjà dit
extrêmement sous pression on est
évidemment obligé d'y répondre alors il
faut quand même rassuré les
téléspectateurs on ne manquera pas
d'alimentation en france certains prix
vont augmenter on va quand même avoir
possiblement très vite des tensions sur
l'eau dans les villes parce que c'est
tour n'a pas parlé mais il ya un robinet
qui coule et un moment il faut arbitrer
et notamment une partie des retenues qui
existent déjà aujourd'hui sur les grands
bassins versants servent essentiellement
à soutenir ce qu'on appelle l'étiage
c'est-à-dire l'été quand il ya plus
d'eau dans les cours d'eau eh bien on
relâche cette eau des barrages pour
qu'on voit déjà que ça existe en réalité
le problème derrière c'est que on est
toujours en train de courir après les
crises on les subit en cours après et
que on est incapable aujourd'hui de
planifier puisque c'est le terme qui a
utilisé le président de la république à
la fois économiquement et aussi plus
largement territorialement parce que ce
qu'on sait aussi c'est que le changement
climatique ce sont des transformations
du climat sur la france c'est à dire
qu'en fait le les climats remonte vers
le nord donc le climat méditerranéen qui
est aujourd'hui
suivi de faire des olives en bretagne
aujourd'hui par exemple on sait qu'il ya
des escrocs on aura de la garrigue
peut-être à lyon on aura du chêne liège
vous allez voyez ce que ces deux chênes
lièges la passion en bretagne ou dans le
limousin donc ça veut dire qu'on pourra
plus cultivé la même chose et donc
derrière on en fait face à une
révolution qui ressemble à ce qu'on a
connu dans les années 50 moi je trouve
que la comparaison elle est intéressante
on est après la guerre c'est ce qui
s'est passé en bretagne le fameux modèle
breton alors on a mis beaucoup de choses
sur le banc des ventes on a beaucoup
cassé du sucre mais ça a été une vraie
révolution pas que technologique bien
sûr qu'il ya derrière de l'innovation
mais ça a été une transformation des
lycées quand vous regardez aujourd'hui
une carte de bretagne vous avez une
densité de lycée professionnel agricole
parce que derrière on avait des agri
managers on a changé les structures de
coopération on a redéployé des routes on
a redéployé les terrasses est ce que
vous êtes en train de décrire en fait
c'est un changement aménagement du
territoire c'est un changement de
société en santé c'est un changement
structurel qui doit être effectivement
accompagné et on doit toujours se
demander l'argent que je mais est ce que
c'est un art je sais ce que c'est un
investissement ou est-ce que c'est oui
c'est de la responsabilité de la région
n'en ou de l'exécutif la planification
doit se faire au niveau national parce
qu'on a des besoins déquilibre ensuite
par contre la tactique est l'adaptation
est
fait au niveau local le 12 avril les
ministres la transition écologique de
l'industrie d'agriculteurs ont
réunissent des préfet coordonnateur de
bassin d'orage a privé d préfet
coordonnateur de bassin pour anticiper
au maximum les dispositions à prendre
afin de préserver au maximum la
ressource concrètement ça veut dire quoi
frédéric cette année à savoir qui va
couper l'eau où on voit la coupe et a
acquis on va allouer la ressource et qui
on va faire payer encore plus demain il
faut savoir que la france a un modèle
qu'elle exporte les pâtes les sacs à
main et les rafales il ya les agences de
l'eau le mode de c'est plutôt une
réussite d'ailleurs c'est une réussite
est exportée dans beaucoup de pays du
monde ont en gros par fleuve à chaque
chaque fleuve coule dans un bassin
versant et chaque bassin versant est
géré par une agence de l'eau c'est très
technicien et qui est dirigé par un
comité de bassin sera parlement de l'eau
à l'échelle des rivières qui sont les
influents de ces fleuves ya aussi des
petits par le monde qui sont les
commissions locales de l'eau ça marche
très bien sauf que l'état leur demande
de donner 100 millions de plus sauf que
l'état leur compte déjà l'essentiel de
leur budget pour alimenter l'office
français de la biodiversité tout en
demandant aux agences de l'ue de
s'occuper et d'eau et de biodiversité
cherchez l'erreur et des sols traités à
l'agencé adour-garonne il lui manque je
crois entre 300 et 400 millions d'euros
pour achever ses missions derrière tout
ça il ya une vraie question c'est que à
mesure que l'imprévisibilité de la
ressource augmente à mesure que les
usages augmente à mesure que le coût de
traitement de l'eau pour la potabilisée
a augmenté à mesure que l'agriculture a
besoin de plus en plus d'eau l'eau va
coûter de plus en plus cher et c'est toi
les piliers sur nos factures par des
redevances alors même que l'état
voudrait que l'on consomme moins mais si
on consomme moins il y aura moins de
redevances qu'on va se retrouver avec un
modèle qui fonctionne bien mais qui est
en train d'arriver tout doucement sur le
mur de son financement et qui va
financer ce sera forcément nous avec
sans doute et c'est une demande je
termine des agences locales des
commissions locales de l'eau enfin des
établissements publics et territoriaux
de bassin qui demandent de pouvoir lever
une taxe locale ce qui est interdit par
la constitution en plus des redevances
prélevées par les agences de l'eau bref
on risque demain d'avoir au moins une
ligne de plus sur notre facture d'eau
pour financer simplement la continuité
de ce service
de ce service de look et qui était pas
un bien commun mais qui est un bien
public endroits ce qui est pas tout à
fait la même alors parmi les réponses et
notamment parmi celles qui ont été
avancées par le gouvernement aujourd'hui
il ya la constitution de stockage jours
de pluie dans des
méga bas si j'ose dire je sais pas
comment ça s'appelle regardez un extrait
de ce reportage de fabien becker dans le
marais poitevin avec justement la mise
en place d'une d'une méga bassine d'eau
c'est un gigantesque bassin de 2 145
mille mètres cubes or voilà là on est
devant la la première réserve de
substitution du projet de la sèvre
niortaise dans quelques semaines cette
réserve permettra de stocker de l'eau en
provenance de la nappe phréatique pour
irriguer les cultures de céréales le
principe pompée dans la nappe en hiver
quand elle est pleine d'eau de pluie et
stocker l'eau en prévision de l'été le
principe de substitution c'est de ne
plus prélever justement pour les
agriculteurs ne pas prendre l'eau en été
au moment où les cultures ont besoin
mais malheureusement au moment où la
nappe est la plus fragile donc vraiment
le principe de substitution c'est de
remplacer ces prélèvements d'été par un
prélèvement divers donc qui est mis dans
une retenue étanche pour être utilisé
l'été en clair ce système ne ferait que
différer dans le temps l'utilisation de
la ressource en eau seize réserve
doivent être creusés dans le sud des
deux sèvres pour un coût de 60 millions
d'euros financés en grande majorité par
l'état à la tête d'un collectif de
plusieurs associations julien leghait
combat inlassablement le projet
concrètement ce type d'équipement
correspond clairement un projet
d'accaparement de l'eau est un bien
commun au profit de quelques-uns alors
mathieu les réglages je vous ai vu rouge
il est consterné par le reportage et
parce qu'on disait non c'est pas
concernés alors on a eu un bar hen de
l'eau dont on a finalement peu parlé
dans les médias qui a révélé aussi des
tensions énormes autour de cette
ressource
d'abord le problème c'est qu'on on a un
discours général un discours local
localement parfois effectivement les
stockage d'eau peuvent être importants
nécessaires indispensables
être une bonne idée mais temporairement
c'est à dire que ces infrastructures la
doivent vraiment
être temporaire pour accompagner une
transition est en fait ce que risque de
devenir ces infrastructures qui coûte
très cher quand même qu'ils sont très
polluantes qui enlève l'eau des sols
justement c'est en fait que le giec
appelle une malle adaptation c'est à
dire qu'en pensant résoudre un problème
à court terme on va le décaler dans le
temps parce qu'on compte dans les mêmes
frais d'un second pont parce que ça
transforme milieu parce qu'il peut y
avoir des pertes parce que c'est très
émetteurs et surtout parce que ça ne
permet pas d'engager les transformations
indispensables en termes de pratiques
culturales parce qu'en fait si ces
mesures là elles permettent aux
agriculteurs de gagner du temps pour
cultiver autrement pour desserrer l'étau
pour aussi avoir d'autres moyens c'est
nécessaire mais souvent en fait c'est
one shot c'est exactement comme dans
d'autres cas vous allez faire la
climatisation vous allez mettre le canon
à neige vous allez vous dire ah ben
tiens je vais remplacer voilà je
remplace la cigarette parce que j'ai
fumé pendant longtemps weisser je me
connais un paquet puis j'ai travaillé
avec mon patch ça n'est pas soutenable
et et le sujet effectivement qu'elle a
c'est qu'avec une pression qui va encore
s'accroître parce que le changement
climatique est là parce que ses limites
elles sont de plus en plus atteinte et
bien en fait on on laisse penser que le
le garros enfin voilà que la pression se
relâche alors qu'en réalité elle est
toujours là et que cet argent il a été
dépensé pas de la bonne manière et donc
on est entre en fait de vulnérabiliser
les agriculteurs au lieu de les
accompagner tôt pour changer les termes
en deux modèles de production parce que
moi je me pose une question est ce que
notre modèle agricole est toujours le
monde d'une certaine façon est ce qu'on
produit les bonnes culture saison autant
besoin d'eau dans un pays qui en aura de
moins en moins amène son barda l'eau
mais c'est exactement la bonne question
puis je veux réagir avec à ce que disait
malgré lui aussi c'est à dire que si on
a une feuille de route si on a une ligne
de mire qui est partagée est quand même
là je pense que tout les scientifiques
autour de la table sont tous d'accord
sur ce qu'il faut faire comment il faut
le faire donc ça c'est la première chose
et après comment ce qu'on a une béquille
à droite une béquille à gauche c'est
très bien mais surtout qu'on ne se met
pas martel en tête en disant que si on
fait des bassines partout c'est la
solution si on change pas nos pratiques
ça sera pas la solution elle que
challans pose la question parce que ce
qu'ils consomment le plus docile
des céréales je crois plutôt le blé ou
entendent oui le maïs imaginez qu'en
france on produise moins ou plus de
céréales parce que ça consomme trop nous
il faut qu on baisse notre production en
changeant notamment c'est ce qu'on
appelle le flexitarisme quoi c'est
comment est-ce qu'on veut diminuer la
consommation augmente autre chose qui
est pas pas autre chose mais en
quantités différentes c'est en quantités
différentes comment est-ce qu'on a
changé de ses habitudes là à part
communiqué à part éduqué dans les écoles
est-ce qu'il faut pas commencer par les
cantines canton car des screens colère
on
marche sur la tête séduit les élus
polita la luz est une démocratie luz et
la politique effectivement quand un
maire heureux casse un contrat avec un
industriel qui fournit les cantines de
son école primaire en disant moi je des
agriculteurs en conservation des cendres
à moins de 10 kilomètres pour fournir sa
marche c'est un levier nantes on rassure
les high rider 91 de moins en moins de
la conservation des sols moins en moins
rares c'est vraiment ce qu'on veut faire
parce que effectivement à la gestion de
l'eau ils font un plan au niveau
national mais vous le disiez à juste
titre c'est au niveau du local aussi que
ça se passe on arrive ici on arrive avec
une espèce de feuille de route déjà tout
tracé enfin plus à quel schéma surtout
les la population va pas s'en accaparer
va pas s'en saisir alors que si vous lui
dites à écouter là j'ai une solution qui
marche dans la commune d'à côté qui
permet d'alimenter les cantines
scolaires sur cette taille là avec des
produits sains qui sont locaux qui sont
bas peut-être de mon voisin et qui vont
peut-être mon emploi demain va forcément
il ya une adhésion derrière qui est
beaucoup plus importante et nous c'est
ce qu'on prône ce gros souvient fréquent
et aussi du mal qu'on eut parfois
certains agriculteurs à se convaincre
qu'il fallait pas polluer les nappes
phréatiques et arrêter certains anglais
il mais farid et fall un des principaux
ball agences de l'eau c'est ça justement
des agences de l'eau pardon subventions
les agriculteurs pour par exemple savez
les causes de pollution des rivières sur
les têtes de bassin les ruisseaux c'est
à dire au tout début d'un bassin versant
cesser la vache qui va faire son gros
caca ou son groupe hippie dans le
ruisseau pas simplement on donne des
sous la halle agriculteurs pour mettre
des clôtures c'est aussi bête que ça ou
alors on lui demande de passer
depuis m d'engrais sur sa prairie la
housse klaus eux se trouvent pardon une
aire de captage ou alors on va l'aider
on va le financer pour pour qu'ils
passent en bio de façon à ce qu'ils
n'utilisent plus de pesticides par ce
combat de son chant il ya une rivière
importante qui coule c'est le boulot
principal de l' agence de l'eau ça
aujourd'hui sont on le sait pas le genre
de l'os et mystérieux mais c'est un des
principaux leviers pour aider le monde
agricole le monde agricole a changé en
lien avec avec les élus locaux qui sont
aux têtes qui sont à la tête des agences
de l'eau d'ailleurs loup c'est vraiment
de la politique donc la joie bien les
solutions qui se dessinait avec ses des
changements de société à long terme à
court terme dans les trois-quatre mois
qui viennent est ce qu'il ya des
solutions concrètes à mettre en place et
déjà on a on a un problème indemnisation
de ces agriculteurs on a une réforme
l'encours du fonds d'indemnisation des
calamités agricoles qui est un régime
spécifique faut absolument les
accompagner moi ce qui m'inquiète et là
où il ya un point d' alerte c'est qu'on
voit bien qu'il ya deux choses qui se
passent une crispation
on l'a vu avec le reportage que vous
allez sur les gilet jaune une crispation
sur les territoires où on voit vraiment
que les gens n'en peuvent plus parce que
c'est l'agriculteur essor du coc vide
parce que la crise parce que donc c'est
très très violents et je pense que là il
faut vraiment avoir un voile à se
remettre à plat et retrouver des
mécanismes effectivement de dialogue
deuxièmement faire très attention parce
que là aussi sur l'alimentation les
pratiques alimentaires ne sont pas
toutes les mêmes on a déjà en france qui
n'ont même pas accès à la viande parce
que c'est devenu impossible et d'autres
qui en mange tellement qu'ils sont
malades or ce que dit le giec c'est que
l'alimentation c'est de la santé c'est à
dire que quand vous allez travailler sur
l'alimentation vous allez travailler sur
le déficit de la sécurité sociale la
réalité c'est ça et donc il faut
calculer aussi l'écho bénéfices cela que
j'ai en partie on exactement après moi
je n'ai pas tout à fait trois-quatre
mois là non
j'entends que vive sauf qu'ils en
arrivent parce que les crises en fait
elles vont se tendre et qu'on risque
d'avoir une succession de crises
sociales de crispation sur le pouvoir
d'achat on a vu dans le débat des
élections sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
l'alimentation sur les écoles avec des
élus locaux qui vont être sous pression
est là on va arriver sur des questions
de sécurité sociale au sens large et
donc effectivement là il faut était là
il est absolument important
d'accompagner de soutenir mais on va les
avoir pour le pongiste d'inchy francs
sur les vagues de chaleur
10019 la canicule dont on a encore en
mémoire il y avait pas le bac y avait
tout ça une chance sur 50 dans dix ans à
1,5 c la trajectoire qu'on a aujourd'hui
17 degrés sein de global on arrive un
degré 5 c'est à dire en fait hausse 0,4
de plus qu'actuellement on est à une
chance sur 10
si on arrive à deux degrés on sera à une
chance sur 4 par an ça veut dire qu'un
été sur 4 en moyenne
on aura des vagues de chaleur on aura
des sécheresses avec en plus des
conjugaisons sécheresse flash on a dix
ans et ce que nous disent les
scientifiques et vraiment c'est un
message d'espoir c'est que les solutions
existent elles sont moins coûteuses que
l'inaction elles vont apporter à tout le
monde du bien être et du mieux vivre et
elles vont aussi derrière pouvoir
retisser la démocratie mais ça veut dire
que derrière il faut que nos acteurs
politiques quelles que soient leurs
bords se mettent autour de la table
qu'on arrête les caricatures sme a fait
soupirer dans votre reportage c'est
qu'on est toujours sûr en fait des gens
qui ne se parlent pas et que je pense
que toute l'expérience qu'on a un
travail c'est que dès qu'on est sur le
terrain il se parle et ça marche et que
quand on voit les initiatives locales
sur l'agroécologie
ça veut dire qu'on a des agriculteurs
qui retrouve le sens du métier cette
fierté on a des locaux qui sont heureux
c'est vraiment un moyen aujourd'hui de
faire en sorte que nos territoires
vivent vivent mieux et donc c'est pas du
tout un discours de déclinologues de
catastrophisme décroissance et il faut
changer aussi dans la tête des
consommateurs
les
consommateurs qui ont déjà changé leur
manne 7 mais en face il n'ya pas irai
pas de il n'y a pas d'offre tout
simplement donc nous qu'est ce qu'on
fait on travaille justement à structurer
cette offre et vous l'avez raison à
structurer cette offre au niveau local
et pourquoi il a même fait passer le
poids des lobbys de la documentaire que
pas que il ya plein de raisons mais
après on peut voir le verre à moitié
vide où on le voit à moitié plein
volontairement et comme quand est ce
qu'on peut faire ya plein de solutions
qui existent et les trous dans la
raquette on les connaît un c'est la
transformation c'est la logistique
beaucoup parce qu'on commence à avoir
regardé nos un agriculteur qui fait la
vente directe généralement il a pas de
problème il vend tout par contre quand
il vend par des intermédiaires il sait
pas à qui ça va il sait pas qui
consomment sais pas quel prix s'est
vendu c'est pas comment s'est
transformée si ça devient des pattes du
pain ou d où je ne sais quoi ils
gagnants - jeux en bois et là c'est
différent parce qu'il fait du volume et
puis il ya des aides etc mais en tout
cas l'idée c'est vraiment de dire que on
travaille l'amont et l'aval il faut pas
oublier tous les maillons au milieu et
c'est tout l'objet de la résilience
c'est à dire que c'est une approche
systémique si vous mettez tout votre
poids sur deux trois maillots temps
qu'un maillon même tout petit qui
n'existe pas votre système n'est pas
résilient frédéric dieudonné on approche
de la conclusion de cette émission c'est
un enjeu qui est en train de devenir
très politique l'eau tellement politique
je vais faire ma propre pub que je suis
en train d'écrire des programmes courts
pour la télévision française qui seront
diffusés après le jt de 20h de france 2
justement sur les solutions qui sont en
cours et il ya plein de choses j'ai
rigolé en voyant le grand bassin parce
que juste à côté j'ai perdu le nom de la
ville et un grand bassin qui va être
alimenté par l'eau de retour de la
géothermie dire qu'on a on a une ville
qui est alimenté par la géothermie les
radiateurs une fois qu'ils ont chauffé
l'eau y la balance ça partait à la
rivière avant et donc ça flingue et ou à
45 degrés les agriculteurs sont dit vous
avez qu à nous l'envoyer dans le bassin
pendant l'hiver j'aime pas et on va
l'utiliser cet été voilà ça c'est un
terreau que c'est pas forcément une
mauvaise idée ces bassins non mais quand
on tape pas dans le milieu naturel et
quand c'est pas aussi grand l'on
récupère une ou que paravent été jeté
trop chaud des cabinets lumineux naturel
ben voilà c'est du circuit de course et
on l'a on fait de l'écologie on
réutilise une eaux usées c'est parfait
cet été il n'ya pas de mauvaise idée en
fait temps quand on va dans la même
direction mais ce qu'il faut pas perdre
de vue c'est qu'elle est notre direction
et sahel les documenter et nos élus en
cette responsabilité là moi je jeu
j'aime bien la proche quand même
régionales parce qu'en france c'est leur
compétence et ils ont la compétence
vraiment les régions pour investir et
c'est donc ils ont la nécessité d'avoir
la vision de leur territoire pour créer
des coopérations entre l'école les
communes qui sont consommatrices celles
qui sont plus productrices etc et c'est
hyper important qu'ils aient leur rôle à
jouer et qu'on leur redonne leur place
mais ils peuvent pas tout donc nous
c'est vraiment vraiment ce qu'on peut
porter il ya des solutions qui existent
pas rencontrez vous parlez vous et
derrière ça marche eh bien merci
beaucoup ce sera le mot de la fin avec
quand même d'un peu d'espoir et un peu
de solutions qui se dessine merci à tous
merci un mag anyresa merci hermine
chambard de l'homme merci frédéric
d'henri merci laetitia